[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique pour un
débat consacré à la santé en bourgogne
franche comté le monde de la santé se
porte mal manifestation pour sauver les
hôpitaux de proximité personnelle en
grande souffrance médecin absent dans
les zones rurales
pourtant dans notre région la bourgogne
franche comté le budget de la santé est
évalué à 8 milliards et demi d'euros
chaque année
et oui 8 milliard et demi et c'est un
chiffre qui est délivrée par la rs
l'agencé régionale de santé pour
débattre de ce thème donc trois invités
claudie chauvelot du banc elle est
conseillère régionale socialiste vice
présidente du conseil général de haute
saône
elle est également présidente du conseil
de surveillance de l'hôpital degrés elle
se bat pour le maintien des urgences
dans cet établissement
face à elle didier martin lui il est élu
de la côte d'or député la république en
marche son expérience professionnelle
pourra nous être très utile puisqu'il a
été jusqu'à son élection à l'assemblée
nationale médecin à l'hôpital de dijon
sa spécialité neuroradiologue et puis
pascal udry c'est le secrétaire du chsct
le comité hygiène sécurité et conditions
de travail au chu jean minjoz à besançon
ils travaillent dans cet hôpital depuis
plus de 30 ans et les de la cfdt
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez commenter
cette émission grâce au hashtag dit mme
paul bfc comme dimanche en politique
bourgogne franche comté première partie
de cette émission le diagnostic
[Musique]
pour bien comprendre ce qui se passe
dans le monde de la santé dans notre
région donc diagnostic sur un secteur
qui est vraiment mal en point or degrés
à saint claude en passant par clamecy
les fermetures des urgences de nuit où
des maternités suscitent de nombreuses
manifestations d'habitants d'élus et de
personnels de santé
on écoute je manifeste de pour soutenir
l'hôpital degré étant donné que j'ai eu
un infarctus et qui m'ont sauvé donc je
ne tiens pas les as des as pigeon ou à
besançon
parce qu'à 40 kilomètres je serais morte
enfin à baisser le ton des ro cerrone
verte
on risque d'avoir des séquelles alors
qu'on a tous plateau technique sur
l'hôpital de clamecy la saint claud
donner voilà pour elle à lons le saunier
il ya 45 minutes de route quand il fait
beau comme ça avec la neige
1h30 facilement et c'est juste pas
possible humain n'existe pas avec la
grèce c'est que des chiffres
[Musique]
pascal udrih on va commencer avec vous
donc on dit qu'en france on a le
meilleur système de santé du monde
peut-être est-ce que vous pensez que ce
système est en danger est ce que vous en
tant que professionnel depuis plus de 30
ans bien vous ne soyez pas soignant est
ce que vous êtes très inquiet ah oui oui
oui tout à fait et l'inquiétude alors
les nos deux élus parleront certainement
beaucoup plus que moi de l'aménagement
du territoire moi je me sens très sûr la
représentation des personnels le contenu
métier a tellement évolué dans la santé
en règle générale ce pour un
établissement comme le chu
il y à une représentation de plus 120
métiers identifiés
donc il ya des corporatismes fort qu'il
faut forcément effacé vous dit pas lobby
vous dites corporatisme là pour mal
quand on en reparlera points cody
chauvelot vous donc vous défendez les
urgences de l'hôpital degré un chiffre
l'agencé régionale de santé dit que dans
un service des urgences
s'il ne passe pas au moins onze mille
500 personnes par an dans ce service il
faut le supprimer
on entendait une dame qui disait on est
dans une logique économique et pas dans
l'huma vous vous êtes tout à fait
d'accord avec cette réflexion-là à tout
à fait complètement aujourd'hui on
demande aux directeurs ou directrices
d'hôpitaux de gérer il leur a pu talent
comme une entreprise
maintenant on qualifie les patients de
clients et tous hommes désole énormément
je me fais beaucoup beaucoup de soucis
pour la prise en charge au niveau de la
santé des personnes notamment dans les
zones rurales
alors on va voir juste deux séries de
chiffres pour bien planter le décor
avant de donner la parole aux députés de
la république en marche
selon l'agencé régionale de santé il
manque en bourgogne franche comté de 150
à 200 médecins urgentistes
il y en a actuellement 472 en poste et
puis autre chiffre vraiment très
éclairant cette fois-ci l'analyse et de
marie-guite dufay la présidente du
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté qui elle estime qu'il manque 2 140
généralistes mille médecins spécialistes
et 880 infirmiers est-ce que vous en
tant que député et en tant qu'habitant
de dijon vous partager ce sentiment
d'inquiétude part
on manque je comprends tout à fait le
sentiment d'inquiétude
je comprends surtout que le personnel
qui est compétent qui est dévouée est
sous pression depuis plusieurs années
avec une réforme de l'hôpital plusieurs
réformes successives dont seul
visiblement ils n'ont pas le temps de
s'adapter à une réforme qu'il faut en
faire une autre
oui on peut dire comme ça il y à une
tarification à l'activité donc une
course à l'acte afin de préserver des
budgets c'est pas de l'argent qui vit en
plus mais juste pour préserver les
budgets et dans les hôpitaux où j'ai
travaillé longtemps je peux témoigner
que dans les quelques années qui
viennent de passer l'activité a augmenté
de 2 3 4 % par an ce qui est
considérable alors que le personnel les
effectifs va que j'avais j'avais invité
un opposant au gouvernement actuel
alors je parte je partage le diagnostic
est le constat de la situation dans les
hôpitaux
c'est différent mais ce que vous pensez
que la safer lui yannick emmanuel macron
donc et tout pouvoir est à l'elysée
la situation visiblement ne s'arrange
pas puisque le plan régional de santé
qui a été présenté par le directeur
général de la rs et refusé par toutes
les collectivités territoriales ont leur
te demande bien quand même de gérer les
pénuries
moi je ce plan régional de santé je les
étudier précisément je pense qu'il ya
des bonnes mesures d'ailleurs même
présidente de la région concédé qu'il y
avait de bonnes mesures
mais le côté régional la refuser la
rejeter dans son antre où est alors
évidemment certains élus locaux qui
voient leurs structures de proximité
menacés ou réduite sont absolument
contre voulait dire que les conseils
régionaux sont des défenseurs de leur
territoire avant d'avoir une vue globale
régionaux et départementaux et au delà
ce sont les maires et des équipes
locales qui évidemment on la population
en face à face et qui partage
effectivement quelques inquiétudes
quelques alors sur les soins non
programmés tel que nous l'avons vu dans
le petit sujet de présentation
c'est assez différent dit des sourires
ans à mes soins non programmés dans le
langage courant selon les urgences
investisseurs alors ces urgences
elles sont très variées
les des petits bobos il ya des urgences
vitales et puis aussi dans certaines
structures beaucoup de personnes qui ne
devraient pas y être admis dans ces
urgences
il devrait être présenté accompagné des
territoires vous parliez des territoires
on voit bien que les uns et les autres
que ce soit que ces régionales ou d'un
conseils départementaux
c'est auprès de lobby tout à l'heure
vous êtes aussi des défenseurs de vos
territoires avant d'avoir une vue
globale des choses mais tout à fait nous
sommes des défenseurs de territoire mais
nous sommes des élus responsables ont
fait bien ce dont nos concitoyens ont
besoin
nous avons besoin d'une médecine de
proximité et je ne comprends pas à
l'heure où l'on manque de médecins de
généralistes de spécialistes qu'on ne
s'appuie pas justement sur l'hôpital de
proximité au lieu de le démanteler les
mots lire j'ai parlé du cas que je
connais par coeur mais ça c'est un clic
à clamecy partout partout partout
aujourd'hui en s'attaquant aussi aux
urgences et dire qu'au maintien en
service d'urgence est fausse et jouer
sur les mots un service d'urgences ne
peut fonctionner qu'avec des urgentistes
et deux en permanence parce que lorsque
nous avons un smur qui est sorti il faut
qu un urgentiste soit l'un soit présent
pour accueillir les personnes les salles
et les possibilités les ce que nous
propose monsieur directeur de l'ars est
monsieur pribyl ne tient pas ce n'est
pas possible chez la femme des hôpitaux
de proximité
alors justement monsieur prix be le
directeur général de la rs pierre pribyl
justifie le regroupement des hôpitaux au
détriment de certains établissements on
va l'écouter tout de suite
c'est tout le sens de ce projet régional
de santé n'ont pas de dépeupler ou de
détricoter une offre de 100 proximité
mais bien d'organiser une coopération
pour une sorte de chaîne de solidarité
quelque part s'organise pour que tout un
chacun de nos concitoyens en tout point
du territoire puissent accéder aux
services auxquels il ya besoin en
proximité si c'est possible ou plus loin
voire même parfois en dehors de notre
région vous savez pour des soins n'est
plus techniques sur les cailloux mieux
centre de référence n'est pas dans notre
région ça s'organise et c'est l'objet du
projet régional de santé que de
l'organiser
[Musique]
alors juste une petite précision qui a
son importance une invitation avait été
lancée au directeur général de la rs
pour participer à ce débat
et malgré le large éventail de
propositions
ce soit enregistré que ce soit en direct
etc il n'a pas pu être disponible alors
on parlait tout à l'heure un petit peu d
urgence moi j'aimerais qu'on arrive
quand même à je vais vous donner un cap
précis et vous allez me dire et vous
médecins et vous qui travaillez au chu
de demain jo si c'est normal ou pas un
homme de 82 ans qui est brûlé à son
domicile
il arrive aux urgences on le soigne et
puis les renvoyer chez lui quelques
heures plus tard c'est sa fille qui le
reconduit avec sa voiture à son domicile
une visite de contrôle une semaine plus
tard pas de chance la plaie s'est
infectée subit alors une greffe et il
doit rester plusieurs jours à l'hôpital
alors plusieurs questions se posent
pourquoi n'est-il pas garder aux
urgences pourquoi n'a pas être n'at-il
pas été transféré au service de
dermatologie ou alors en cardiologie
parce qu'il est cardiaque
vous n'êtes pas soignant mais répondait
nous monsieur idrissa seck
c'est un problème c'est pas un problème
je suis pas soignants je suis dans
l'hôpital de plus + 35 ans et lui ai
donc je connais un petit peu les rouages
normal la réponse non bien sûr mais
c'est la conséquence de positions prises
antérieurement et de certaines réformes
qui se sont succédé sans jamais être
assimilée donc le problème il est il est
simple vous l'avez vous avez parlé de la
t2a cerné de la région tarification à
l'acte 1 oui donc les gens viennent aux
urgences et les gens des urgences qui
sont sous une organisation en pôles ont
d'autres pôles dans l'établissement qui
eux mêmes sont soumis à l'activité pour
maintenir un budget ils sont
indépendants les uns des autres voilà
donc le monsieur qui est moins aux
urgences c'est un acte et les urgences
touche quelque chose non c'est pas
vraiment ça c'est à dire que l'on laisse
de côté la personne qui rend aux
urgences on mais quand il rentre aux
urgences quel que soit le diane
diagnostic dermato ou autre il faut
après un lits d'aval comme on dit sauf
que les lits d'aval sont dans des pôles
qui
eux mêmes sont soumis à l'activité donc
les lits sont remplies et comme on a six
seront appelés par des gens qui vont
ramener d'argent au service exactement
donc comme tout ces dernières années on
est resté sur ce schéma là il n'y a plus
aujourd'hui de quoi placer quelqu'un qui
mériterait peut-être une à deux journées
d'hostilité retiennent de surveillance
on n'a plus cette surveillance on arrive
à faire réagir la mécanique on va faire
réagir le médecin néanmoins du pic ait
pas d'accord sur un point
courir après l'argent courir après
l'activité c'est pas pareil il y à une
rationalisation des équipements et il y
à une réduction des nombre de lits du
nombre des lits et donc ses places ses
lits d'aval parfois manque que ce soit
après une opération où que ce soit au
moment d'une admission en urgence il
faut rassurer quand même notre
population
les gens ne sont pas soignées ou pas
soigné en fonction données qui doivent
rapporter ces faux mais c'est bien de
dire déjà quand même il faut le dire
très formellement
est-ce que des fois ils peuvent avoir
quand même une impression différente
là ce monsieur il aurait dû être gardé
quelques jours à l'hôpital c'est pas un
art un mois je ne dis pas que la plaie
ne se serait pas infecté je dis
simplement que c'est choquant une brute
envoyé ce n'est pas la venue de gravité
de cette brûlure
fallait-il le garder huit jours à
l'hôpital s'il était resté huit jours à
l'hôpital orange il eut cette infection
ou pas on n'en sait rien à me prononcer
c'est un peu caricatural par exemple
mais ça d'exemple vrai à tous les
exemples vrai l'infarctus c'est vrai
l'accident vasculaire cérébral c'est
vrai ce qui compte c'est d'avoir les
outils dans l'unité d'admission pour
faire le diagnostic précis ça veut dire
de la biologie ça veut dire de
l'imagerie médicale est ensuite
appliquée le bon traitement est bien
dans le réseau d'organisation des soins
je crois qu'il faut avoir les moyens de
faire le bon diagnostic directement ou
avec de la télémédecine dans certains
cas afin de trier les degrés d'urgence
est acheminé des patients pour qu'ils
aient le meilleur soin alors
correspondant allons parler des urgences
je suis désolé vous êtes responsable du
chc c'était il ya eu une doc une femme
médecin aux urgences à l'hôpital de
besançon qui a tenté de mettre fin à ses
jours
il ya deux mois est-ce que ça ça a
vraiment marqué dans l'opinion publique
un médecin des urgences qui tente de
susciter dans son service
vous avez demandé un audit etc
est ce que c'est vraiment révélateur
d'une très grande tension dans ce
service et qui reflète le malaise
général des personnels de santé
alors ça affecte tout le monde dans le
sens où il ya une solidarité parmi les
agences pitallier qu'ils soient agents
du secteur médical ou paramédical ya une
vraie vraie solidarité oui bien sûr que
ça touche ça affecte pour autant un
chsct n'est pas là pour gérer des cas
individuels
en réaction à le chsct se positionne sur
des organisations de travail essayer de
pallier au mieux aux risques
psychosociaux pour les cas individuels
il y a la structure de la santé au
travail les médecins du travail qui
prennent en charge ce faisant le cas
qu'ils le font très bien d'ailleurs
donc je crois que
vous avez dit je suis pas soignants dont
j'ai aucune légitimité à me positionner
mais si on lit ça a été quand même un
choc c'est dans l'hôpital et à
l'extérieur mais bien sûr que ça
interpelle c'est interpelle mais il y a
plusieurs mois que l'on travaille sur
les conditions de travail
vous avez parlé d' audit c'est pas un
audit que le chsct a demandé si on peut
rester là dessus c'est un second espère
t-il pour risques graves convoi jusqu'à
mort mais extérieur justement qui est
donc les conclusions s'imposeront au
chsct aux directions et alors alors
monsieur martin donc j'ai eu cette
semaine de téléphone le responsable de
l'ordre régional des infirmiers de
bourgogne franche comté qui voulais vous
poser une question justement en tant que
vous député de la république en marche
qu'est ce que vous avez comme solution
pour aider les personnels soignants qui
sont en grande souffrance alors
premièrement il faut sortir de la
logique budgétaire actuel et assouplir
se résume ce régime de la t2a de cette
course à l'activité saas et
réglementaires il faut réorganiser le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital
ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut en urgence
prendre en compte le stress des
personnels le fait que les congés
maternité ne soient pas remplacés que
les congés maladie ne soit pas remplacé
et l'activité augmente donc forcément le
personnel craque comme pour reprendre
votre expression
donc ça il ya des moyens qui doivent
être affectés et j'ai entendu le
président macro dire qu'il y aurait des
moyens pour l'hôpital et publics en
particulier parce que c'est celui de
madame madame souffle du banc qu'est ce
que vous en pensez des moyens
supplémentaires pour l'hôpital vous
réagissez comme ans annoncé par emmanuel
macron jeudi et bien j'attends de voir
j'espère que les moyens seront à la
hauteur mais à la lecture du plan
régional de santé
on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui et bien
la santé c'est devenu une affaire de
chiffres sont plus qu'une immersion
c'est emmanuel macron jeudi n'a pas
donné de montant il l'a pas dit mais
est-ce que si jamais donc on vous
annonce quelques millions pour l'hôpital
est ce que vous pensez que de l'argent
ça suffit ou pas l'argent ne suffit pas
qu'est ce qu'il faut aux russes fin il
faut remettre en cause beaucoup beaucoup
de choses mondiale mode de tarification
nous en avons parlé mais j'attends de
voir aussi le personnel
souffrance les patients également vous
avez des personnes qui songent l'hôpital
degrés mais dans tous les hôpitaux
également nous avons des gens qui sont
sur les brancards et en côte et ça on
ferme des lits moi j'ai du mal à suivre
est ce qu'on peut comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui quand on parle de la
santé aurait zone de la même façon que
lorsque l'on parle de la sncf venir en
chiffres alors qu'on choisit par en
prendre un train mais on ne choisit pas
d'être malade on ne peut pas traiter la
santé de la façon de tout la traite
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment être très
précautionneuse faire attention on a
entendu on a entendu il ya 10 ha de bois
agnès buzyn la ministre de la santé
quand elle était un petit peu eu un
petit peu sifflé lors de sa visite à
neuf est elle avait dit il faut savoir
faire preuve d'imagination vague
imagination parlons-en les pins
d'innovation l'innovation si c'est fermé
les hôpitaux de proximité et bien bravo
pour moi c'est pas une innovation c'est
une destruction de l'égalité hausse de
l'égalité aux soins et c'est dromensa ce
donc je crains et de fermer les hôpitaux
de proximité de fermer les services
d'urgence ça va contribuer à des
maillets totalement nos territoires
ruraux
pascal udrih par rapport justement à
cette ce besoin d'innovation prônée par
la ministre de la santé c'est ses
limites une insulte imaginez ce qui se
passe dans les services bloc opératoire
l'urgent services de soins le personnel
s'adapte au quotidien fait preuve
d'innovation au quotidien pour
différentes raisons pour le flux qui
s'accélère pour l'évolution des
technologies il faut être en permanence
aujourd'hui en formation canton et
soignants pour pour s'adapter justement
nouvelles technologies accompagner le
personnel le les patients pardon donc
l'innovation elle est de fait elle est
acquise mais l'innovation et luz c'est
le contenu métier a complètement changé
alors pour expliquer pourquoi le
personnel est à bout aussi c'est que
quand on prend la tarification à
l'activité qui devait rapporter un
certain nombre de moyens aux
établissements qui s'y prêtent
le gouvernement n'a rien trouvé de mieux
que de dire à une époque puisque ont
fait un certain nombre d'actes qui usent
le personnel puisque le travail plus
qu'avant
puisqu'on fait un certain nombre d'actes
on va des côtés l'acte c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans la formule
travailler plus pour gagner moins
donc forcément en interne des
établissements ont énormément de mal à
travailler avec moins à gérer le
personnel avec moins à gérer les flux
avec moins et quand vous parliez tout à
l'heure des gens qui viennent aux
urgences c'est une désorganisation
totale de la médecine de ville qui est
la conséquence de ce qui a été fait
jusqu'à maintenant alors que quand on
dit médecine de ville ce sont les
médecins à haute autour de autour de
nous qui sont des médecins généralistes
pour la plupart qui travaillent plus
comme avant vous aviez des confrères je
pense que vous avez commencé qui faisait
60 70 heures par semaine
maintenant les médecins ont envie de
vivre comme tout le monde c'est normal
il y a aussi une féminisation de la
profession a maintenant c'est la faute
des femmes
ah bah voilà à j'ai pas dit que cette
saison j'ai dit que justement et je
considère que leur demande est légitime
elles veulent travailler à temps partiel
elles veulent pas de même des hommes un
design travaillé à temps partiel même
des hommes mais si vous savez lire la
vie les maternités
la famille s'est aussi beaucoup la
sphère des femmes des mamans et des
médecins quand elles sont mamans et bien
elles font des choix des choix de vie et
elles veulent travailler à temps partiel
c'est vrai en milieu rural il y à une
chute de la démographie médicale
on manque de médecins généralistes et
notamment dans la nièvre par exemple on
a beaucoup de territoires mais c'est la
nuit que la médecine de ville et les
points de suture qui se faisait au
cabinet du médecin c'est terminé la
radiologie de proximité pour voir s'il y
avait une fracture et le médecin qui
faisait à plate s'est terminée en
maladresse qu est ce que les médecins ne
correspondent pas un lobby très
important dans la loi de l'ancien
ministre de la santé madame bachelot il
était prévu que les médecins
s'installent sous certaines conditions
dans des zones rurales et puis ça c'est
tombé à l'eau parce que les médecins
vous êtes extrêmement puissant et que
après 10 ou 12 ans d'études
vous pensez que vous avez le droit de
vous installer où vous voulez c'est pas
faux ce que vous dites par ce même homme
serge même un peu vrai parce que les
internes
moi je les connais je travaillais tout
pendant tout mon temps vous l'avez était
excusé vous l'avez donc je sais bien que
pendant quatre ans cinq ans six ans il
donne beaucoup il donne beaucoup en
continu vous le savez très bien
c'est c'est pas 40 à 50 heures sans eux
l'hôpital ne fonctionnerait pas cette
voie là c'est clair avant que je
n'aurais pas comme maintenant je dois
dire aussi que ce personnel médical
taillables et corvéables à merci
on lui demande beaucoup aussi je prends
l'exemple du scanner quand j'ai commencé
à faire des scanners cérébraux
on faisait en général 20 25 scanner la
journée et puis on nous faisait entre 5
et 10 la nuit
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt 70 le jour et
70 la nuit parce qu'on est en continu
avec les 50 un patient arrive on ne peut
pas seulement avec ses mains faire un
diagnostic donc il ya une avalanche
d'examens complémentaires pour une
médecine de qualité et c'est ça qu'il
faut bien avoir en vue c'est pas les
chiffres mais la qualité des soins leur
vous vous seriez d'accord pour qu'on
impose l'installation de certains
médecins en haute saône par exemple dans
les coins où il y en a pas beaucoup
il faut réfléchir à tout ça il faut
réfléchir seulement avec les médecins
parce que moi je serais plutôt partisan
tu vas garder cette liberté
d'installation
mais avec une certaine contrainte
cependant c'est à dire que comme pour
dans certains métiers
ma foi lorsqu'il ya un médecin qui part
à la retraite à nouveau le remplace et
les il est conventionné
sinon aussi libre à eux de s'installer
men sont pas conventionné je pense que
c'est comme ça qu'on peut aussi résoudre
le problème mais encore une fois par
rapport à cette démographie médicale
dans nos campagnes qui pose beaucoup
beaucoup de soucis il faut s'appuyer
justement sur les hôpitaux de proximité
et connaissent cagliari qui veut dire un
petit mot
skf pas beaucoup de temps pascal udrih
très très rapidement non mais c'est
encore une fois c'est la conséquence
d'innombrables décisions prises ces
dernières années sous l'influencé de
corporatisme y compris du conseil de
l'ordre des médecins et ont créé
d'autres conseils de l'ordre aujourd'hui
et le problème de la santé
c'est pas que chacun a raison dans son
coin il faut aujourd'hui je vais dans la
provocation sicile malaisie allez y
lâchez vous l'agriculture aux
agriculteurs la santé aux médecins on
n'a rien compris à la politique de deux
territoires
d'organisation des organisations voilà
donc je pense qu'il faut rétablir un
dialogue social avec les personnels mais
par les entendre pour les entendre faut
les entendre pour faire avec de vraies
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la santé
doit être géré avec les médecins pas de
santé sans médecin c'est clair mais pas
de médecin sans personnel c'est clair
aussi et du personnel en bonne santé
donc il faut faire avec les directions
qui représente les directives les
médecins les les 1000 le ministère la
grèce mais il faut faire aussi avec
alors vous êtes d'accord
installation des médecins son
conventionnement par exemple en haute
saône ou dans la nièvre
vous seriez d'accord vous en tant que
médecin et en tant que député je veux
pas me prononcer pour cette mesure la
libre installation égale libre choix
aussi libre accès des patients qui peut
aller voir ailleurs dans certains coins
de haute saône ou de nièvre le patient
il a plus le choix du tout il en a un à
30 kilomètres à la ronde
que n'a plus de médecin spécialité qui
manque cruellement à main vous pouvez
venir à gré de spécialité comme ça on
n'a plus le choix
voilà donc du coup il ya des personnes
qui se font pas soigné parce qu'elle n'a
pas l'âge offre de juste une petite ils
peuvent se quand il n'y a pas d'urgence
et qui sont valides et qu'ils soient
accompagnés
on pense qu'aujourd'hui en france tout
le monde peut être soignée y compris
gratuitement quand il a pas les moyens
de se soigner il faut quand même rester
quelques fois comme chez des
spécialistes soit gynécologue son
ophtalmo faut attendre des mois pour
avoir un rendez vous c'est vrai je dis
plein de choses vraies vous avez
remarqué
moi je voudrais comme vous poser une
petite question un peu plus politique
quand en fait on a su que le produit
intérieur brut le pib de la france était
2% au-dessus de ce qui avait été prévu
pour 2017 certains députés certains
sénateurs de droite et de gauche ont
proposé que ces petite cagnotte soit
utiliser prioritairement pour les
hôpitaux et pour les ehpad les maisons
de retraite et le premier ministre a
répondu que quand on a un pays aussi
endetté que notre il n'existe pas de
cagnotte et que cet argent devait servir
à rembourser la dette
vous avez commencé votre
présentation en parlant du coût de la
médecine un chiffre en milliards d'euros
pour huit milliards et demi pour la
bourgogne franche comté 200 milliards au
niveau de la france sachez que pour la
france c'est environ 10% du pib
11 est considérable même ordre entre dix
et nous nous arrivons aujourd'hui avec
je reconnais des souffrances et parfois
des dysfonctionnements un équilibre des
comptes sociaux
c'est une bonne chose nous arrivons
également un équilibre des comptes de la
nation avec un retard de l'état je
consens par rapport aux collectivités
locales mais nous arrivons à sortir du
déficit budgétaire chronique est
excessif tels que l'europe l'avait
proscrit
donc nous devons rétablir la bonne santé
économique de notre pays pour ensuite
pouvoir financer la solidarité dont la
sécurité sociale donc la petite cagnotte
c'est pas pour les ehpad et les hôpitaux
pour tout de suite
savez il ya beaucoup d' équilibre
budgétaire et les priorités seront
nombreuses et nous verrons qui est puis
il ya beaucoup de mécontentement quand
même hein quand on voit les facs la sncf
la justice pour le premier anniversaire
de l'arrivée à l'elysée des manuels
mâcon c'est un peu difficile
il nous reste 30 secondes vous savez du
rhin une seconde quand on innove
quand on met en pas en place les
parcours de santé pour les patients
quand on se concentre sur le patient
lui-même quand on met en place les
groupement hospitalier de territoire
quand on n'innove certaines évaluations
c'est sûr qu'on dérange après il faut le
faire dans le dialogue et la
concertation et toujours garder en tête
le soir pour tous et la qualité pour
tous voilà donc on va suivre
attentivement ce que emmanuel macron a
promis deux choses donc l'abandon du de
la tarification à l'acte pour les
hôpitaux et davantage de moyens pour les
hôpitaux en france
merci madame merci messieurs on verra si
c'est pas une carabistouilles comme il
est employé ce mot là jeudi à midi
merci de votre attention et puis bon
dimanche à tous au revoir
[Musique]